this morning nearly three out of every
four intensive care hospital beds are
occupied across the country
as the coronavirus pushes the nation's
health care system to the brink
the u.s saw 105 000 new cases on friday
a sharp decline from the all-time high a
week ago
overall new cases are beginning to trend
down but
more than 118 thousand people remain
hospitalized in this country
the disease has killed more than 330
thousand americans
and there are concerns of post-holiday
search michael george has the latest
even as the number of cases push doctors
and nurses to the limits
americans aren't showing signs they'll
ring in the new year
with safety more than 7
million people cleared tsa for flights
out of u.s airports in the week before
christmas
less than half the number of travelers
from a year ago but still
more than public health officials would
like if what happens over the winter
holiday break
is that all the same as what happened or
even half of what happened over
thanksgiving holiday
we're in deep trouble los angeles is
already severely
impacted from an after thanksgiving
surge there's been a four-fold increase
in cases
patients die at the rate of one every 10
minutes
what we're seeing now is essentially a
significant change in the demographics
nearby in riverside dr stephen patterson
works in the emergency room graphics we
are still seeing a great number of those
individuals that are part of our
vulnerable populations the elderly those
with chronic illnesses but we're also
seeing people who are in their
20s and 30s early 40s while the behavior
of some young people has been identified
as
irresponsible and dangerous a wisconsin
granddaughter went out of her way to
protect her grandmother yesterday
grandma we got you a few presents at an
assisted living center
chelsea lambert benefited from a
visiting booth volunteers had built
to keep grandmothers out of harm's way i
don't think
they'll ever know how much this means to
people
because i know it can't be easy being in
here
for this long you know but
it's the holidays and duke university's
women's basketball team
announced it will sit out the rest of
the season for safety
this is not a time to remain fatigued
with vaccines on the way dr patterson
speaks for many with his own
holiday wish think of the people around
you
and your actions and as you go about
your day
think about those decisions that you
make will i take my mask off here
or will i decide that i would like to go
out to eat here
for cbs this morning saturday michael
george
new york